this is Startalk what kind of private
donation systems exist to supplement
funding NASA projects or other planetary
science research well I'm sure this
person is referring to the Kickstarter
program for start talk radio wait or for
a shuttle is there Kickstarter to raise
billions the only donation system I know
it's called taxes really I mean I don't
know yet but you'll probably know I mean
as far as NASA goes NASA is but NASA
gets his budget based on the tax top but
the way that NPR various places that are
partially public partially private get
money is there a thing like that where
he could be like you know what I'm gonna
give seven billion dollars to NASA well
there is one that I know of and I'm not
an expert on all of them that there
might be but the arkad telescope this is
a idea where they're going to make
telescopes to look nominally to look for
asteroids but the proposal is to have
one pointed at the earth and then you
the user the online happy person can in
get that telescope to point at anything
you want and it sounds very romantic to
go Mount Everest but maybe you know your
neighbor's yard what have you so if the
lights are on when you're away for
example how it is way anyone can access
it
anyone who's my don't understand the
price structure exactly but you give so
much money to arkad or AR KY d and they
will give you access to the telescope
based on some formula and I imagine do
you hear that very creepy people I don't
think I like this idea well so we're
gonna dome over my house yeah well I
don't know what the resolution would be
and how much value be but what do you do
when you download Google Earth and get
it running on your computer what's the
first thing you do you live your second
gene some of that time in Texas right
there was Eugene